yeah i think it's kind of important for  him to uh to actually like the guys  like first uh  russian team  it's exactly the opposite like they  would normally  bring all the biggest guns in  like it doesn't matter if they're  farting if they're fighting or if  they're friends or whatever i mean  basically  you just use all the power yeah i mean  here we i mean it's a european approach  mostly yams basically  mostly you care about  some atmosphere and so on and then only  then you need people to work well still  sometimes i feel like i'm responsible  for the chess part like all these guys  are nice guys and i'm not a nice guy but  uh  i mean  someone has to work  hard it's kind of a problem otherwise i  would never yeah i would never be in the  team but i'm joking of course i think he  i mean in general he kind of he kind of  likes us and  tends to trust us in general then yeah